let's get to round one though and let's
start
with
the spot where the draft began yeah we
knew trevor lawrence was going to the
jaguars we knew zack wilson was going to
the jets no mystery there everyone was
two for two in their mock drafts
yes and then for many it went off the
rails because
most had mac jones
some idiots had justin fields or should
i just say idiot ours
uh but but it became
that guy whose name had been percolating
and gurgling and emerging in recent days
north dakota state quarterback trey
lance let's hear from your buddy kyle
shanahan explain yourself kyle on why
you went with a guy who only played one
game last year
when we made the trade we knew exactly
where we were going what we were doing
now we want an opportunity to go and
look at everybody we've been very high
on trey since the beginning since day
one
and yes the person everyone else is
speculating about we liked him too um
but it was just
honestly to go through this whole
process where
you know no one has known you know my
friends coaches anybody um how john and
i feel and how we felt this whole time
let me just say this
i don't believe it first of all and
second of all this was all one big
unforced error by the 49ers and the best
contrast this occurred to me yesterday
chris
the falcons
because
the falcons
never
got into any type of a public
wishy-washy
giving credence to the idea that they
can go in a bunch of different
directions building a mystery so people
pay attention to them
and
and and it never felt like
the falcons weren't quite sure what they
were going to do
it felt for so long like the 49ers made
this big move
and they're not quite sure what they're
going to do and didn't we predict
earlier in the week this is exactly what
they'd say oh that was our guy all along
yeah all that other stuff now this was
our guy all along
no you you said it you said it from the
start uh you're right i don't know i
don't believe that either i'm going to
be honest with you yeah i don't believe
it was treylands from the start i mean
i'm as shocked as anybody you know i i
hope every maybe this gets everybody off
my back to think every i every word i
say or damn is back i know
i know everything about shanahan i don't
oh they definitely won't think that now
no they won't that's over i mean we have
conversations certainly definitely i was
shocked though no i thought we were
gonna see mac jones at number three and
my friend who i know has you know
great admiration for a guy like matt
ryan and especially drew brees uh that's
always the guys he talks about i thought
for sure that's where he would go in
this you know and and even to open the
door a little bit more like yeah we had
some conversations right after the
college season and i thought that's
where maybe i got my lean on mac jones
too all right so that's where i thought
for sure
knowing him what he likes at quarterback
everything like that it'll be mac jones
so when that pick happened last night i
was not a part of any grand conspiracy i
was like oh my gosh he went with trey
lance i cannot believe it i mean i was
in shock i really was and do i agree
with it no i don't i don't i don't think
trey lance was worth the number three
pick of the draft but it doesn't matter
what i think shanahan obviously has the
confidence in his ability and
you know at the very least
i'm excited to see what he can do with a
guy like trey lance i am i mean again we
saw what he did with rg3 and that type
of skill set trey lance is raw as a
thrower as a passer there's a lot of
room to grow you know it's iffy it's not
a hunt it's risky it's not a 100 that he
will grow and become what we think
that's why i didn't make him a top three
quarterback in in my draft listing but
you know the athleticism is real
and
that's where he's going to bring a
different element to the shanahan
offense and i think that's probably a
big reason of why kyle decided to go
with this trey lance route at pick
number three
in an interview on espn kyle shanahan
referred to trey lance as a very good
backup and said it's going to be very
hard for a rookie to come in and beat
jimmy garoppolo out he's a good player
right so i like the situation we're in
blah blah blah look more bs it's bs it's
bs you can't do it you had a guy who
played one game last year you're gonna
sit him on the bench for another year
exactly gave up three first-round picks
and a third round pick for a guy that
you're gonna put on ice for a full year
bull
you know what yeah to that they're
trying to build trade value for jimmy
garoppolo plain and simple that's what's
going on and here's the other side of it
too remember
because they
played this game of who are we going to
take what are we going to do we showed
up for the ferrari we like the porsche
we like the aston martin who knows what
we're gonna do tune into the draft to
find out well
they could have had mac jones at 12 the
way the board fell and i know that if
they were sitting there at 12 maybe it
would have gone differently maybe they
wouldn't have gotten mac jones maybe the
patriots would have jumped them who
knows
but they could have had mac jones
without giving up two extra first round
picks and a third round pick based on
the way things fell that puts even more
pressure on them to get the most out of
trey lance and putting him on the bench
for a year is not going to be a good
idea so
we understand that there is strategic
lying that happens from coaches and gm's
you have to understand that and now job
number one for the 49ers given they have
trey lance in the building is to get the
most they can for jimmy garoppolo and
trade him at the right time and that
look every team that drafted a
quarterback last night except for the
top two the ones where it was who knows
what they're going to do and who have
other quarterbacks on the roster what do
they all say it was the bears andy
dalton's our starter the patriots
cam newton's our starter so
i i'm a firm believer that part of the
development of the quarterback is
letting him build confidence internally
by beating out the starter so for trey
lance job number one is go beat out
jimmy garoppolo it's not gonna be easy
trey you're gonna have to work hard trey
you're gonna have to show up early trey
you have to study your you know i think
this is all the carrot that gets dangled
in front of this guy so he becomes what
they hoped he would be when they gave up
all that stuff to get him i i agree with
you there i i do i mean listen
i'm with you and your thought like you
you don't trade up to number three to
put a guy on the bench for a year that's
definitely not what you do and mike i
think your point there that that's the
most real point and a part of the risk
again of trey lansin why i wouldn't have
taken him a number three you know you
said it it's a guy with really low reps
of throwing the football as is anyways i
mean wait there's a stat right that it's
like the least
he's there we go 300
fewest college pass attempts in the last
40 years so you have that right
we know for a first round quarterback we
we so there's so little we know about
the guy still to this point and then you
bring up the point mike about you know
sitting him for a year that that's to me
the one of the problems with lance there
you can't sit him for a year
he's already just sat a year he's got to
play quarterback and football at some
point so you can't do that he's going to
have to play to me you're you're risking
a lot by sitting them on the bench and
going hey guy that hasn't played a lot
of football here's another year of hey
not playing a lot of football that would
make no sense to me at all so i would
think again and not that i know this so
hope everybody can get off my back with
this crap
that
yes shanahan's going to say this for now
we're going to see if trey lance can
come into otas and rookie minicamp and
just look the part get the offense as
long as he doesn't crap his crap down
his leg or crap the bed right mike i
think that's for you or both right then
i think that's when you'll start to hear
you know train lance will be our starter
and you're gonna start to hear the jimmy
garoppolo trade rumors
yeah i think you're right and again
you've got to build confidence i
remember
when ryan tannehill was the eighth
overall pick nine years ago and the
dolphins put him at three on the depth
chart yeah and i knew then
this is all about helping ryan tannehill
acquire the confidence necessary to go
play in a game on sunday because he
believes and maybe the others need to
see as well that he's capable of
knocking off the guy who's at number two
that's right the guy who's at number one
and
assuming that jimmy garoppolo is even on
the team when training camp opens i'm
still not ready to sign off on that but
if he is this is for the benefit of trey
lance and for the locker room to see why
they believed so fervently in trey lance
to make that move to get trey lance to
give up three first round picks
ultimately in a third round pick for one
player and it's a player who is as
unproven as any first round quarterback
really has been in decades he's well
suited though to the bob greasy version
of the kyle shanahan post season offense
where you only throw eight times
he's only thrown 318 times right right
yeah hand it off hand it off hand it off
that that's what uh that's where i think
it's it's it's interesting and to me
that's where yeah i thought i think
shanahan probably
erred on trey lance because of what
you're talking about first off
shanahan's baby is his run game that's
where he separates himself from the rest
of offensive coordinators and and
offensive game planners all together
it's a special run game it's really
creative you know people always steal
his stuff do those things you're seeing
other offensive coordinators from his
scheme start to you know end up around
the league more and more here
now
this is gonna give the offense a totally
different look that it's not gonna be
like hey wait we played green bay and
the jets already oh we have a good feel
for this offense and what they do you
know we played minnesota with kubiak
some of their run stuff now that he's
gonna have an element that you know
nobody
really is ready for and you're gonna see
i think
a
kyle shanahan lamar jackson-ish type of
offense that's what you're going to see
here going forward i think that's to
what to expect and you know that's
that's another thing listen i like trey
lance there's a lot of top end talent
another question i though have a little
bit here is
i don't know how good his running is
that would be the other thing i would go
this is not lamar jackson like let's
it's not that lamar jackson was four
rockets up his butt didn't matter who
they were playing you were like whoa
this is the fastest guy on the field
this guy's really athletic he's got
quick feet and all that but i don't know
how
athletic and explosive it's hard to tell
too he's playing against a bunch of one
double a players who run 4-7 and 4-8 so
that's the other thing too i just don't
know how great he can be in that aspect
to me which also adds to the risk but
i i think that's what shanahan's
thinking and it will be
a bastard for lack of a better phrase to
stop his run game when he has a
quarterback that we see can do that rg3
type stuff
there is another element to what the
49ers did yesterday and more accurately
what they did or tried to do on
wednesday night that we'll discuss
next segment but it makes it even more
important that lance becomes the guy
that they expected him to be when they
made that move up if he was the initial
choice and if it was a process of
confirmation not elimination to settle
on the north dakota state quarterback
but
i i'm bugged by what happened wednesday
night and also what was said about it
last night by john lynn
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports